>> WE ALSO UNDERSTAND THE NEED
TO KEEP THE ECONOMY GOING TO
PROVIDE FOR OUR FAMILY AND QUITE
FRANKLY WE KNOW HOW TO DO THAT
BEST.
>> WE NEED OUR LIFE BACK.
WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO WORK.
>> THERE IS A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
THAT ARE HURTING, NOT JUST
PEOPLE GETTING SICK FROM THIS
VIRUS.
BUT PEOPLE THEIR ENTIRE LIVES
ARE BEING UPENDED BY.
THIS.
AINSLEY: MANY OF THOSE
PROTESTERS SAYING END THE VIRUS
NOT THE ECONOMY.
LET’S BRING IN DAN BONGINO, FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR, FORMER SECRET
SERVICE AGENT.
FORMER NYPD AUTHOR AND HE HAS A
PODCAST.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU, DAN.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU IT’S BEEN A
WHILE.
AINSLEY: GOOD TO SEE YOU.
PROTEST IRAQI SECURITY FORCES
GOING TO TAKE PLACE DOWN IN YOUR
STATE IN FLORIDA.
10 PROTESTS TAKE PLACE TODAY
ALONE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT AND DO
YOU SEE BOTH SIDES OR ARE YOU
LEANING IN ONE DIRECTION?
>> WELL, AINSLEY, RARELY HAS
THERE BEEN A TOPIC I HAVE BEEN
SO PASSIONATE TO GET ON THE AIR
AND DISCUSS THAN.
THIS OF COURSE I SEE BOTH SIDES.
I HAVE A FAMILY AND I HAVE TWO
CHILDREN MYSELF.
I HAVE A MOTHER-IN-LAW AND TWO
PARENTS THAT ARE STILL ALIVE
THAT ONLY I CARE DEEPLY ABOUT.
MY MOTHER, HERSELF, HAS BEEN IN
EXTREMELY HIGH RISK CATEGORY.
IF SHE WERE TO CONTRACT.
THIS IT COULD BE DEADLY.
BUT, AINSLEY, I HAVE TO FEED MY
KIDS, TOO.
SO DOES EVERYBODY ARRANGED ME.
AND I WATCHED THAT CLIP BEFORE
THE BREAK OF NANCY PELOSI
SEEMINGLY CONFUSED ABOUT WHAT
PROTESTERS WERE DOING.
LET ME ENLIGHTEN YOU, NANCY,
BECAUSE YOU SEEM TO BE LIVING
ANYONE SLATED $25,000 FREEZER
ICE CREAM BUBBLE AND YOU DON’T
GET IT.
HERE IT IS PLAIN AND SIMPLE.
PEOPLE HAVE TO FEED THEIR
FAMILY.
THESE ARE SMART AMERICANS WHO
ARE INTELLIGENT.
THEY UNDERSTAND THERE IS A RISK.
THEY LIVE WITH RISK EVERY DAY.
IF YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT
NANCY GO, TALK TO A CONSTRUCTION
WORKER ON A CONSTRUCTION SITE
DOWN THE BLOCK THAT IS LIVING
WITH MULTI-MILLION-DOLLAR
EQUIPMENT THAT COULD KILL HIM IN
A MINUTE.
IF YOU TELL HIM OR HER ON THAT
SITE YOU’RE GOING TO NEED TO
WEAR A MASK.
THERE ARE PRECAUTIONS.
YOU MAY HAVE TO WEAR SOME KIND
OF HAND PROTECTION.
WASH OUR HANDS OFTEN AND WE MAY
HAVE TO DISTANCE, BUT YOU WILL
BE ABLE TO GO TO WORK AND FEED
YOUR KIDS.
I PROMISE YOU THE
ENTREPRENEURIAL BRAVE AMERICAN
CITIZENS WILL FIGURE IT THE HELL
OUT.
GET OUT OF YOUR BUBBLE.
PEOPLE HAVE TO FEED THEIR KIDS.
THAT IS WHAT IS GOING ON RIGHT
NOW.
BRIAN: DAN, I WILL TALK TO YOU
AFTERWARDS, BUT JUST TO GIVE
PEOPLE AN IDEA WHAT THEY MIGHT
HAVE MISSED IS NANCY PELOSI’S
45U89INGNANCY PELOSIHALTING DELI
PROTESTERS ARE UP TO.
>> CAN YOU UNDERSTAND WHY THEY
ARE DOING THAT?
>> NO, NOT REALLY.
BECAUSE WHAT WE HAVE TO DO IS,
IS SHELTER IN PLACE.
THAT IS REALLY THE ANSWER.
TESTING, TRACING, TREATMENT,
SHELTER IN PLACE.
AND I DO THINK THAT IT’S
UNFORTUNATE.
BUT, YOU ARE NEGOTIATION PEOPLE
WILL DO WHAT THEY DO.
THE FACT IS WE ARE ALL
IMPATIENT.
WE WILL ALL WANT OUT.
BUT WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS
REALLY UNFORTUNATE.
BRIAN: WHAT THEY’RE DOING IS NOT
UTTER.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS
EXERCISING THEIR RIGHTS.
THEY COULD HAVE BEEN SOCIALLY
DISTANT PROTESTING I GET THAT
THERE ARE PLACES THAT ARE HOT
SPOTS.
DAN, IF YOU DO PUT IN SPRINKLERS
FOR A LIVING AND INGROUND ONLY
DO IT CERTAIN TIMES AND WEAR A
CERTAIN MASK.
LET THEM DO IT.
IF SOMEBODY WANTS TO BUILD A
HOUSE, ON THE OUTSIDE, DISTANT
FROM EACH OTHER BY DESIGN, LET
THEM DO IT.
THERE’S NO NEED TO BE
ACCESSIBLABLY PUNITIVE ABOUT
THIS.
IS THAT YOUR POINT?
>> YES.
AND, BRIAN, WHEREAS IN THE
BEGINNING WHERE WE HAD A
LOCKDOWN OF OUR ECONOMY
NATIONWIDE, BASICALLY, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE BRIGHT.
THEY UNDERSTOOD THERE WAS A LOT
OF UNCERTAINTY IN THE BEGINNING,
THE RO.
THE THREALITY WAS IT.
IN THE BEGINNING BECAUSE WE WERE
GETTING A LOT OF INFORMATION.
EVERYBODY UNDERSTOOD IN THE
EFFORT TO SAVE, YOU KNOW,
POTENTIALLY AT THAT POINT WHAT
THEY THOUGHT WERE MILLIONS OF
LIVES.
THE PRESIDENT MADE THE RIGHT
DECISION.
NOW WE HAVE OUR GRASP AROUND THE
DATA.
YOU DON’T NEED TO BE AN
EPIDEMIOLOGIST TO READ SIMPLE
FIGURES.
WE HAVE A BETTER GRASP.
WE DON’T KNOW EVERYTHING.
IT’S ONLY REASONABLE THEN TO
ALLOW AMERICANS TO TAKE THE DATA
YOU HAVE GIVEN THEM AND TO SAY
HERE ARE THE APPROPRIATE
MEASURES FOR YOU TO GO BACK TO
WORK AND BE ABLE TO FEED YOUR
KID.
ONE MORE THING, BRIAN.
NANCY PELOSI CAN’T FIGURE OUT WE
ARE DOING?
THESE PEOPLE, GRETCHEN WHITMER
AND OTHERS.
NOT JUST DEMOCRATS EITHER.
SOME REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS, TOO.
THEY WORK FOR US THAT’S NOT A
SLOGAN OR CAMPAIGN TALKING
POINT.
NOT RUNNING FOR OFFICE.
THEY WORK FOR US.
MAKE OUR LIVES EASIER NOT MORE
DIFFICULT.
WE UNDERSTAND THERE IS A SAFETY
ISSUE.
STOP TALKING LIKE THIS IS LIKE
ROMPER ROOM.
WE ARE NOT CHILDREN.
WE ARE ADULTS.
WE LIVED MUCH HARDER LIVES THAN
THESE PEOPLE GOVERNING US.
A JOKE THE WAY THEY TALK TO
PEOPLE.
I DON’T UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY’RE
DOING.
FIGURE IT THE HELL OUT.
THAT’S YOUR DARN JOB TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE ARE DOING.
>> DAN, WHAT I THINK WE ARE
LEARNING IS THAT A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL APPROACH DOES NOT WORK ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY BECAUSE WHERE
YOU ARE SITTING IN STUART,
FLORIDA, IT’S A MUCH DIFFERENT
ENVIRONMENT THAN ABOUT 100 MILES
SOUTH IN MIAMI WHICH HAS BEEN A
HOT SPOT.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
NUMBERS, THIS PARTICULAR ILLNESS
IMPACTS THE PEOPLE OVER 65 IN A
GIGANTIC WAY AND GOING FORWARD
WE NOW KNOW THAT UNTIL THERE IS
A VACCINE THOSE PEOPLE HAVE GOT
TO BE INSULATED.
UNTILUNLESS WE HEARD FROM CHINA
EARLIER WE WOULD HAVE HAD A
BETTER HANDLE ON THIS.
WE HAD JEH JOHNSON ON ABOUT 40
MINUTES AGO HE SAID THE NUMBERS
OUT OF CHINA IN THE BEGINNING
SIMPLY DID NOT ADD UP.
>> IN A COUNTRY FOUR TIMES THE
SIZE OF OURS, I SIMPLY DON’T
BELIEVE THEY HAVE BEEN TOPPED
OUT 83,000 CASES.
I LOOK AT THESE NUMBERS DAILY
CHINA HAS BEEN 81, 82, 83,000
FOR WEEKS IN A COUNTRY OF
1.4 BILLION PEOPLE.
I SIMPLY DON’T BELIEVE THAT
NUMBER.
CHINA HAS TO BE DEALT WITH ONE
WAY OR ANOTHER.
BUT I THINK WE HAVE GOT TO STAY
FOCUSED ON THE LETHAL PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS RIGHT HERE AT HOME
RIGHT NOW.
STEVE: SO, DAN, HOW DO YOU DEAL
WITH CHINA ONE WAY OR THE OTHER?
>> WELL, STEVE, THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE IN LAW AND ELSEWHERE.
BETWEEN MISFEIGNS AND FALL
FEIGNS.
MISFEIGNS IF SOMEONEMISFEASANCE
IF YOU PUNCH THEM IN THE FACES A
THEY GO TO GET UP THAT’S
MALFEASANCE.
THAT’S WHAT CHINA DID HERE.
I THINK MOST PEOPLE UNDERSTOOD
IF CHINA DIDN’T HAVE A GOOD
GRASP OF THE SITUATION AND PUT
OUT SOME INFORMATION THAT LATER
TURNED OUT TO BE INACCURATE IT.
HAPPENS ALL THE TIME ESPECIALLY
IN A CRISIS.
THAT’S CLEARLY NOT WHAT HAPPENED
HERE.
CHINA DIDN’T PUT OUT A MISTAKE.
CHINA PUT OUT DELIBERATE
MISINFORMATION TO PEOPLE THAT
CONFUSED THEM.
AND POTENTIALLY LED TO HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF UNNECESSARY
LIVES BEING LOST IF THEY JUST
WOULD HAVE PUT OUT THE
INFORMATION APPROPRIATELY FROM
THE START AND MAKING IT WORSE,
STEVE, THEY PILED ON IN THE END,
ENGAGED IN AN EXTENSIVE IDENTITY
POLITICS BASE.
UNDERSTANDING OUR SOFT SPOT, THE
UNITED STATES.
IDENTITY POLITICS.
PROPAGANDA EFFORT, USING PEOPLE
IN OUR MEDIA TO COVER UP ANY
POTENTIAL CRITICISM OF CHINA AS
XENOPHOBIA WHICH WAS TOTALLY
NONSENSE.
THE TRUTH TELLERS WERE THE ONES
SILENCED BY SOME, NOT ALL, BUT
SOME IN THE MEDIA, WHICH WAS
REALLY GROSS.
AINSLEY: OKAY, DAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US.
>> GREAT TO BE BACK.